machine knitters often use scrap yarn or
waste yarn to start and end our knitting.
By scrapping on, we can hang weight in the
scrap yarn to make starting the garment
easier and to protect
delicate garment yarn.
We can scrap on both
open and close cast ons.
For both techniques.
Start with a yarn that's similar
in weight to your garment
yarn.
Use any cast on method you choose.
I've used a simple e-wrap cast
on knit, a few Row of scrap.
And then knit one row of Ravel cord.
The ravel cord should be a smooth,
strong yarn of contrast in color.
For a closed cast on, use your garment
yarn and cast on over the ravel cord
stitches.
Continue knitting.
Many knitters will keep the scrap on the
work and it will help shape the piece
while you're blocking.
So don't take it off too quickly, but
this is a matter of personal preference.